now you're looking for a special get  away to paradise well cameron mathison  is here to help all this week I've shown  you how I vacation like a star at secret  sport or Los Cabos golf and spa resort  in Mexico and I can't tell you the view  definitely improved my golf game look at  this amidst a sea of butterflies flying  all around you you've got 18 holes of  Jack Nicklaus and Greg Norman designed  golf right outside the resort's my golf  game was on point kind of but who can  complain on almost 7,000 yard course  with a view like this if you are a golf  fan you do not want to miss this golf  course it is spectacular and thank you  secret sport or Los Cabos for an amazing  getaway